[Music]
good morning
today is a monday morning and this
little boy just
finished his very first day of the
seventh grade
at a brand new school too by the way i
might add in the middle of a pandemic so
we thought this is a day to remember
you're making history i think yeah
how was your first day of seventh grade
my boy it was good
it was fun because you could turn off
your camera
and mute your mic so it's like you could
say
stuff during your class time yeah on the
zoom call yeah
like you could talk to yourself oh like
instead of
regular classrooms yeah you have to not
talk because the teachers
so you can like talk all you want and
never get in trouble for anything
yeah you could put your head down you
could fall asleep and no one ever know
well this is how they do it though if
you like fall asleep during class
you wouldn't know but it just matters on
your grades yeah right
it'll reflect if you're sleeping
throughout the class huh exactly
yeah cause then that means you weren't
paying attention how was it meeting
new people via online because you're
starting a brand new school
i didn't really meet anybody did you
have to introduce yourself or any of
your classes
no we just took attendance we did the
objects
thing the treasure hunt where we had to
do like a scavenger hunt yeah
like around the house yeah but for
important stuff about me
which were the items that you ended up
picking um i picked a
picture of pho and ice cream birthday a
picture
of you guys wedding um me so i created
a photo with the what do you still have
all the things in your room let's
show them right here you guys
which were the items that you used this
is first visit disneyland
and then which one thing that i created
in third grade this is you
my boy and this is mine and this
is us my boy during the wedding so what
was what did each item represent
so what was this for example something
that makes you smile
uh like a photo of your birthday but i
didn't have that so i did this
i gave you a different photo so angry at
these things
it's like i'm happy using that
i don't know just showcasing i'm a
little tired because i woke up early and
this was for
something i created so then did you end
up getting to see
your classmates things too yeah i did
actually it was pretty boring yeah why
is it because there's a lot of students
so imagine
they're all like photos because i have a
photo pho
and then my favorite color is my shirt
yeah and i had to sit through six
people 30 people were 40. i forget whoa
it's a lot of kids
yeah showcasing six items whoa it took a
long time
it took a while so how many classes do
you have now that you're officially
officially a middle schooler six
classes six classes uh each day i do
three of each so three periods um
so it's like period one period two
period three and then tomorrow
period four five and six uh so then
that's how you alternate
and then wednesday you don't have any
homework it's just teach
it's wednesday's meant to catch up on
anything you
like work you haven't finished yet so
it's easy to
work on stuff compared to having to get
piled on with more homes yeah so it's
like
wednesday's like catch-up day catch up
with everything that you've learned and
then all the other days is like new info
yeah do you like your teachers so far
yeah they're pretty cool they're pretty
nice
did you end up getting any homework for
these this first day
yes i did actually and i just finished
it oh
high five dude what time is it it's like
nine
noon yet yeah it's not even noon and
you're already done with school
because i have nate all day today
because i was too excited
oh cute so you have to go eat something
yesterday i just
sat in bed and couldn't go to bed until
12. really
oh my gosh i was just there like i was
trying to go to bed but i was hot so i
took it off so you felt nervous
or like just excited yeah and then i
took off the blanket and then i was
cooling down and i was trying to go to
bed and i put it back on and get hot so
i just sat there until 12 and then i
finally
passed up what were you anticipating
like what were you thinking that it was
gonna be like
because i actually wanted to ask these
questions beforehand but then
in the morning it was just like oh i'm
starting already okay bye we're like
oh dang it's so fast okay good luck guys
have fun yeah we're just like cool okay
have a good day bye
and then you close your bedroom door but
yeah so what were you anticipating
before
all right let's do school all the
regular stuff and
no friends all lonely did you make new
friends for the first day or
not really you can't really because you
can't interrupt the teachers
so you can't even socialize let me ask
you zero socializing do you have
preferred
to done school in person okay pretend
that their pandemics is gone right like
just nothing's happening in the world
like that
would you prefer being in person or did
you really like this experience today of
being online
i like both because i can be in my room
and then if i'm bored i could turn off
the camera and just lay in bed while
hearing it
because i was bored so i late ever laid
in bed
and i turned off my camera and i was
listening but i was just relaxing at the
same time
so do you think you retained any of that
information i did actually
really what was it they were talking
about doing your google drive and stuff
oh so it's just like overview like
simple things yeah not really new
information
and then how do you guys have homework
we do yeah what's our homework i didn't
know we had homework yeah
yeah what do we gotta do basically what
you have to do is you
uh need to basically write stuff about
me
like for the teacher to know really
that's cool
so like anything any problems i have
like if you were to say like
a joke not to make that joke or if i
oh like things that you might be
sensitive to yeah that's cool
so they could get to know you better and
your your personality yeah that's pretty
cool that's really
thoughtful because none of my teachers
ever cared i like this school district
already
new school i kind of want to go in
person though but then i'm not
at the same time i know right because we
went to go pick up your books
uh last week i think it was so we got to
see your school in person
it was really nice it's a nice school
it's just i like this better because
being at a new school
having to be with people you don't know
mm-hmm i guess that's why i like this a
little better yeah it's
anxiety yeah you have to meet the people
in person and like
be all awkward sitting right next to
them yet true
you can kind of like learn them via zoom
right now
and then warm up to them warm up to it
and then meet them later on in the
school year
yeah so it's like you kind of know them
it's less
anxiety yeah compared to starting in
person
that's true because i could see that
being kind of like um
like a really really long icebreaker
version of this so you can get to
meet new people in a brand new school
are you okay dude yeah
you're just like rolling around i'm like
are you you're good i'm doing what is
when he smells daddy oh that's what
you're doing okay
because i'm like you i know you're
pretending to be something but i just
didn't know like a old snake or worm
you're being so stinks
my head stinks i have a lot of uh
well the cats appreciate it i don't know
what it
it's hard to explain though what it
smells like it's just head
no but it tastes like something why are
you eating it i'm not no no
it's like you taste the smell of
something because you know when you
smell stuff you taste stuff
sometimes yeah maybe it's because you're
hungry maybe
all righty i'm gonna go play video games
wait so you're not gonna eat
oh aren't we ordering food oh true
[Music]
you're so funny you're so cute so i've
spent the day editing and working from
home
jeff just got back home and she came
back home to an
awesome awesome status where was i
though where was i oh you went to the
dentist
orthodontist yeah how's your teeth
coming along they're coming along
yeah yeah somewhere in my aligners but
that's not important that's not
important
this is important it is finally finished
oh well i think i think they said
oh what you're dance in front of me
what you never now like that yeah i
never danced
like ever not necessarily like in front
of you or in front of anyone that's true
so same here i don't i gotta i used to
love dancing when i was
like used to dance a lot you and me
yeah we would dance a lot we were
goofier and we had so much more
going on yeah we just we're getting it
back life came at us too hard
and you know adulting came at us too
hard i guess that's true
but with this though this is like the
party the party area so we're getting
our party back on
getting back into
this is how you do it i don't remember
how to do it no more i don't know now we
dance like parents
yeah side side to side motion right here
wait who's that oh that's that means oh
i just had my arms
who is this who is this person no i'm
just like it looks like you're dancing
up against a pole or something
it looks funny from the last time the
last time we recorded a video about our
backyard
we didn't have the countertops on yet we
don't have
any of that or even the paint yeah this
is gray before so they
really put on they did a lot today
finishing yeah oh
and we didn't record this the other day
but they had this on
like the full piece yeah yeah that was
cut out yesterday
so today they cut it out oh yeah we
didn't record it huh i got the b-roll oh
yay
good job good job we have to now they
put it back in here
it looks really really good summer's not
ending it's okay
we're still gonna have barbecues and
we're gonna have some parties we're
gonna invite everyone over here
yeah we're gonna have fun i know and
is my dance over here
we want to hopefully put our dining
table here
we have to figure out a way to make it
weatherproof because it's technically
not meant for the outdoors
and i never contacted the company
to let them know that they delivered the
table all messed up i
still haven't contacted the company oh
my goodness i don't know why i'm taking
so long i'm doing that but i got to
email them and also i want to ask them
like hey is there any way i can make
this weatherproof because i want to see
if it fits out here
and we want to get a new dining table
for the inside because that one's just
way too bulky but i also don't want to
get rid of it because i love
the fact that it could be extended
that's like
my most favorite thing about it so i
don't want to get rid of it for that
reason but yeah
we want to see if it fits here and if
they'll still be like comfortable
walking space you know see maybe
that's it we gotta see if like a
fountain will fit right here too oh i
can't wait for the town
i know right it's going to be all
tranquil out here you know it just sucks
our ac unit so close to everything you
can't
stay but i saw in the comments last in
one of the videos about our
backyard that you guys were like is that
your neighbor's wall
yeah oh yeah trust us we are like
yeah why is the neighbor's wall here not
a fence when we did have our house set
up there we
like temporarily you know just wanted to
have a hangout spot out here while
we took a break from uh construction
because we had to wait for these parts
to come in so now that they're here we
took the couches away but when we did
hang out here
you could hear our neighbors going up
the staircase and doing stuff inside
their house so it's
yeah so this very right here very very
thin walls even for the exterior so
these two windows are
actually the wall that is going up the
steps
so they have an identical house like we
have
yeah so our stair wall is right here for
them
exactly so we hear the stairs going up
the steps and also when they're flushing
the toilet
oh yeah water's going through the pipes
you can hear that too
so yes this sucks that this is our
neighbor's wall but
that's just what we have like that's
just
yeah it is it is what it is
i guess vice versa i guess we would have
to kind of be not too loud out here
too on the regular we do we try our best
to like just be like
true but during the day i mean it's
daytime
you know true okay but at nighttime we
really do try to be quiet
true and luckily we're pretty quiet
people too like if we don't we don't
like scream or anything
according to the construction worker we
just spoke to before they left
i think tomorrow will be the last day of
construction according to them
this is pretty much all finished and uh
the only thing left to do
will be placing a
post in that little thing oh this one
placing a post here another post right
here
and then we're gonna put one all the way
at the end so we're gonna have these
little
posts popping up from the ground and
since
this is our neighbor's wall and we can't
touch their house
we're going to get as close as possible
to doing that posts are
for the string lights because we're
going to have like all right string
lights so we are able to touch
our house yeah we have to worry about
that side but for this side since we're
not trying to touch their house
yeah we're going to be attaching them to
the poles and the other purpose of the
pools are
for like on the lounge area so the
furniture itself is
really low so there is like your
inevitable
inevitably going to be reclining on that
wall
and so like your hair like my hair kind
of gets stuck to the stucco too so that
we don't like that
so we want to have posts on the side so
then we can
hang like a tapestry right and then
cover that wall
and protect their wall i don't know what
to do but i'm thinking like
draping some vines like getting like
like a mine type of thing oh yeah i like
that
so more green i think yeah i think we
did a good job with keeping it very
neutral in here and a lot of beige how
do you pronounce beige because
one of you guys commented that i
pronounced beige weird
is is beige correct i say beige
yeah me too i call it oh maybe it's not
maybe you said it in your text because
sometimes you're like a batman
beige so you probably went like beige
beige beige stage age beige
yeah you know you ever say use something
so much that it loses meaning
oh yeah we did a good job with keeping
everything very neutral colored in here
pre-colored
inside out here everything yeah even the
ugly fence that we don't like is the
same color
i bought this covering for the grill
specifically to match everything out
here yeah
there's black and i was like yeah this
looks better i think
so now we have a nice canvas of cream
color
and we are going to add our own layer of
plants
and colors flowers the color really is
going to kick in whenever
tiff does this oh yeah she's going to be
painting the tiles so now i have a total
of four
patterns to pick so i just want to play
with
different ones we gotta we gotta do it
on photoshop and play with colors too
true all right so we are back inside the
house and we're parting it up
but there is one person that is not
invited to the party one thing that's
not invited to the party
and it's a fly loki we've been trying to
catch this fly for the past like 10
minutes
five minutes
did you get it i don't know i heard
something but you're the cutest when
you're trying to catch a fly
what what what is your
did i get it daddy's took that over here
oh no
oh no
where'd it go i don't know but i could
watch yourself
i could watch this all day okay okay get
it get it right here don't hit me
get it get it did you get it no where'd
it go leave me alone
leave me alone okay okay
yo it's so close it flew right at the
camera
you know we need a new one of these
things what's wrong with that so flimsy
out of all things to be coordinated with
you're still you're coordinated with
your flesh water
yeah color wise oh there it is there it
is there it is
it was like right it's like right over
the island but i don't see it no more
another update
is we have added this uh
nice key hanger rack
and shelf and we added a lot of the
pictures
so tiff recently went through these
pictures what were you looking pictured
through pictures for
you were doing something else no i just
i got the idea that i couldn't put
photographs here and so i was like oh
i'm gonna go find the photographs that
we have somewhere
so i unearthed them and then you
realized that it made it feel more like
a home now
yes it did there's also some more
upstairs but the reason why i brought
them out though was to
for the oh right yeah because this was
what made you want to
by the way shout outs to this artist
because she
she sent me her art but actually you
know what's funny
she actually technically addressed it to
just kidding news
so more than just me but i kept them
because it's so pretty
sorry how am i gonna share like put it
up in the office
this is like garbage it's trash
you'll never see it here for when we
come in
from uh wherever we are because the
garage is the first thing we see
every time we come in okay i can't
remember the artist off the top of my
head
but you're seeing it right now on the
screen in post because it's in text
i love your art it's pretty there's more
pictures upstairs
oh yeah some more wedding photo
the youtube 100 subscriber plaque
100 100 000 sorry 100
000. look at this cute little baby photo
the buzz right by my ear like taunting
me it's taunting you what are you gonna
do about it tiff
what are you gonna do about it get get
it i wish i had more control
this thing bends like crazy look
i'm not good at this me neither i
thought it was a lot better because
recently my streak has been awesome i've
been nailing them like in midair
that's the most satisfying when it's
like mid-air and you just catch them you
feel it
like feel them hitting the thing i would
just leave the door open
and let this fly leave i do not want to
be a murderer
but if i do that a whole bunch of other
like insects are going to be coming in
but yeah we have a dead cricket right
there like a right there
dead cricket we have so many bugs in
this new house
true i've actually seen a dead spy oh
yeah a dead spider right here oh it died
it finally died yeah there's a spider we
were avoiding it for a long time
dead spider dead cricket
i've actually seen that spider there for
a couple days in a row now i'm just too
lazy to get it
stupid i blame this look at this
oh you know they have an electrical one
that's like a tennis rack
oh is that oh what i was thinking like
it just it does the swatting motion for
you so you just
you just hold it up like a magic wand
it'll like it'll hit it for you it'll
slap it
it's like an automatic slapper you know
so funny that's good though
but yeah you know it was zapper oh
that's even better yeah
that's so hilarious hurry and catch the
fly so i can start cooking
you catch the fly what the heck then you
start cooking then
[Music]
dinner is served bam you got some
bok choy some rice some chicken
stir-fried
green sauce all righty look what we did
we set up the candlesticks and then look
look
we put string lights on the couch this
is cool i like it we've never done up
the house like all like
moody like this i know and then wait
till we get the under the cabinet lights
oh yeah yeah that's right little accent
lights underneath that'd be cool
bon appetit love you guys cheers
oh yeah i was like do you usually do
something at the table yeah cheers
[Music]
you